quand vous interrogez mon vieux pour
hugo savalli l'effort déjà parce que je
suis pas venu moi je suis très pudique
du surnom est une fois des années des
années jusqu'à ce que je n'ai sûrement
ouais ouais bon bout
[Applaudissements]
désir a du mal et je fais une queue leu
leu tôt cette semaine que le lot tout
seul et tout à l'heure je ferai une
chenille solitaire merci comment vous
appelez-vous à votre votre vous veut
clastiques maman chérie et rapidement ça
devient the king attend des aliments
périmés vous je parlais deuxième match
et rim
oui vous avez bien lu un jour je pense
journaux ce projet maxime cas des
surnoms que j'emploie n'apparaît dans le
classement - le ça est douce bluetooh
chihuahua ah ouais c'est ça qui est
parti vite aux antilles on dit doudou et
vous
j'appelle je les appelle tous deux doux
comme ça a été surtout pas te et voulait
vraiment mon bébé aulas géraldine
maillet alors moi mon amour aujourd'hui
mais les anglo saxons j'ai zappé darling
dans les gares ben moi aussi tu appelles
mais vous avez des amoureuses anglo
saxons sur moi oui je vais alors je suis
très très fort sur tout ce qui est des
points comme quoi irlande tous un peu
fort vous pourrez alors quelle que soit
la personne avec qui nos vous lâcher
quand vous appelez la personne alors
quelques cents à personne avec qui je
couche sentiments ou pas je l'appelle
cyril
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça surprend parfois ça surprend gilles
alors baby coeur quand ça va très bien
tout ou quand ça va bien
et puis un chéri quand ça va moins bien
ah ouais ouais tout c'est un chien dans
ces chiffres n'ont pas tout tout tout
rappelle toutes ces toutous à face à
petra ficta pas titi et futuna
si si tu as des deux journées vous à moi
c'est simplement amour de ma vie non je
m'attends à nantes ou quand elles ont un
goût de madonna ouais mais ça marche
ah ouais bah oui quand il ça marche pas
deux comme un serveur sais rien j'ai pas
de preuves a encore mais ça va un peu
loin ça avance bien les deux savants se
voyait ses beaux s'éclate ans
ouais c'est vrai amour de ma vie pour
passer l'eau lourde m'a dit bon coin et
vous et vous et vous quoi moi oui
comment vous appelez les petits surnoms
le conte petit surnom de vos charges ou
alors faut couvre au meeting
je ne suis pas là dedans et nous mène à
dizy pas de chéri mais c'est pas pareil
c'est pas c'est pas ça moi j'ai au polo
la bombe ont soit un saint vous c'est
pas pareil
enfin parce que vous n'êtes pas comme
nous vous êtes un parent c'est pas
pareil ça non j'en ai trop dessus
non mais m non non non ça marchera plus
ça y est donc déjà dénommé jeunes non
mais non mais stabilo boss aller sur des
trucs qui arrive
[Applaudissements]